We're approaching the endgame of Avengers:
Endgame.
Marvel launches the re-release of the superhero
flick Friday, June 28.
Though the secretive studio has revealed some
information about the new content fans can
expect to see with the re-release, Marvel
has kept quiet on the never-before-seen footage
fans have been most excited for: a, quote,
"unfinished, deleted scene" that will play
after the credits.
Marvel fans everywhere have tossed around
theories left and right about what they might
witness in the re-release post-credits scene.
But thanks to a recent report from We Got
This Covered, we may now have the answer as
to what the sequence actually is.
Reportedly, the post-credits scene featured
in the Avengers: Endgame re-release is focused
on Mark Ruffalo's Professor Hulk.
Unnamed sources close to the outlet claim
that the sequence is about a minute long,
and isn't the type of deleted scene that some
viewers have been anticipating.
The scene, which Marvel itself has confirmed
is incomplete and was cut from the theatrical
version of Endgame, is said to show Professor
Hulk coming to the rescue when a group of
children are in danger.
Leaping into action, the big green guy jumps
into a burning building and rescues the youngsters.
Then the scene ends.
Though it sounds like a fun scene, the sequence
is perhaps more notable for what it isn't
than what it is.
It's not, for instance, a tease to set up
events in Marvel's upcoming Phase 4, which
is still shrouded in mystery.
It's not about Captain America's trip to the
past.
And it also doesn't reveal any hints about
Hulk's future in the MCU - which, given how
likable the character is, is fairly disappointing.
"Well, we're kinda both like fire."
"But Hulk like real fire.
Hulk like raging fire.
Thor like smouldering fire."
The purported Avengers: Endgame re-release
post-credits scene also isn't the much-discussed
deleted sequence featuring Katherine Langford
as an older Morgan Stark.
Langford, whom most know as Hannah Baker on
Netflix's drama series 13 Reasons Why, filmed
a scene in which Morgan Stark appeared in
front of her father, Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony
Stark after he snaps his fingers using the
Avengers' Infinity Gauntlet.
His health quickly fading after powering the
Gauntlet to defeat Thanos and his army, Tony's
consciousness travels to a "metaphysical way
station" where he sees his daughter, now much
older than she appeared throughout Avengers:
Endgame, who forgives him for making the ultimate
sacrifice and leaving her to grow up without
a father.
The sequence is presumably an echo of the
scene from Avengers: Infinity War where Thanos
visits a spirit realm to meet the ghost of
the daughter he murdered, Gamora.
"What did it cost?"
"Everything."
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo clipped the
Morgan Stark scene from Endgame because they
felt it made the already complicated movie
even more complex, but some fans had pinned
their hopes on seeing it in the re-release.
If We Got This Covered's report is to be believed,
though, this scene won't ever roll out on
the big screen.
Still, there's some hope that fans will eventually
get to see that sequence.
Avengers: Endgame is set to be released digitally
on July 30, and on Blu-ray on August 13.
And it's very likely that the bonus material
for those releases will feature deleted and
extended scenes, hopefully including the Morgan
Stark scene.
And even if the purported Professor Hulk sequence
isn't the post-credits scene you were hoping
for, there are still plenty of other reasons
to see the Endgame re-release in theaters.
Even though the re-release is not actually
an extended cut, it does reportedly include
a new introduction from co-director Anthony
Russo, as well as a tribute that's believed
to honor the late Stan Lee, plus a sneak peek
at Spider-Man: Far From Home.
Plus, for the first wave of fans, there will
be a limited number of exclusive, free posters
featuring an illustration of the Infinity
Gauntlet with the bittersweet phrase "We love
you 3,000" stamped along the bottom.
Plus, you know, there's the movie itself,
which is still awesome the second time - or
the thirtieth.
Hopefully all that will be enough to make
up for what could be a pretty unremarkable
post-credits scene in the Avengers: Endgame
re-release.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.